[Applause]
there are echoes of Islamist terrorism a
coordinated assault against Christian
worshippers and hotels popular with
Western tourists suspected suicide
bombers deployed to cause maximum
carnage straight out the PlayBook of
Islamic state or al-qaeda or one of
either of their affiliates but nothing
is known for certain no one has yet
claimed responsibility and no one is
drawing any conclusions we don't have a
lot of information about the suspects
with their Sri Lankan nationals or
otherwise and it is also reported that
some of these attacks by their terrorist
terror attacks they also include suicide
bombings again further information is
not available so we don't know who has
actually carried out these attacks of
what group or groups or what their
affiliations are it will take time to
understand what happened Sri Lankan
security forces have carried out a
number of raids and made several arrests
with the defense minister blaming
religious extremists one possibility is
that this was Islamist extremism perhaps
even a response to the Christchurch
Massacre carried out last month by a
suspected white supremacist targeting
Muslim worshippers another possibility
is that the killings were the work of
other extremist elements Sri Lanka is no
stranger to bombings following a long
civil war but serious violence has not
been seen since Tamil Tiger rebels were
defeated in 2009 though Christian groups
have said they faced increasing
intimidation from some extremist
Buddhist monks in recent years one thing
is certain an attack on this scale would
require sophisticated planning and
expertise not just to coordinate the
blasts but to keep the plot secret
something groups like al-qaeda or
Islamic state have done in the past for
the jihadist is extremely important to
hit Christian targets at symbolical time
so eastern and christmas are
a extremely volatile time and security
services are always preparing themselves
for attacks during those two holidays
fairs have grown since the fall of
Islamic state so-called Caliphate in
Syria that fighters who fled would
launch terrorist attacks elsewhere in
the world Sri Lanka revealed three years
ago that a few dozen Sri Lankan Muslims
left the country to join Islamic state
for now the focus will be on preventing
further attacks and hunting down all
those involved
Deborah Haynes Sky News